الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه كثفت استعداداتها لاجلاء السكان
المحليين في الاراضي الخاضعه لسيطرتها في
منطقتي زابوريا وخرسون الى اراضي شبه
جزيره القرد واشارت الهيئه الى ان القوات
الروسيه اعدت مسحا للسكان من اجل الاجلاء
المحتمل في ميليتوبل واسكادوفسكي حيث تم
التحقق من جوازات السفر وتصاريح الاقامه
ومستوى التعليم اضافت ان رحلاتي دوريه ان
رحلات دوريه للحافلات يتم تنفيذها
للراغبين في الاجلاء مشيره الى ان القوات
الروسيه تنشر معلومات مفردها انه اعتبارا
من نهايه ابريل سيكون الاجلاء قصريا
وفي شبه جزيره القرم اعلنت سلطات المواليه
لروسيا اسقاط صاروخ اطلق من الجانب
الاوكراني على مدينه
فيودوسيا على الساحل الشرقي لشبه الجزيره
اضاف موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي ان الهجوم
لم يخلف اي ضحايا ورجح ان يكون صاروخ قد
اطلق من منظومه للصواريخ في منطقه تزلي
على بعد اكثر من 400 كيلومتر من فيودوسيا
واشار الموقع الى ان السلطات الاوكرانيه
تكثف من استعداداتها لهجوم قد يبدا في
غضون اسبوعين
هذا وقالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه تكثف من بناء خطوطها
الدفاعيه في اتجاهات خرسون
واشارت الى ان هذه القوات تواصل عملياتها
الهجوميه على بخموت وتحاول السيطره على
المدينه من جهه افاد موقع ريبار العسكري
الروسي بان معارك عنيفه تدور بين قوات
فاجنر والقوات الاوكرانيه في محيط محطه
السكه الحديديه بمدينه
اضاف الموقع ان قوات فاجنر تقدمت من
الشمال الشرقي والجنوب الشرقي باتجاه
المناطق التي ما تزال تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه وكان مالك شركه فاجنر
قد اعلن قبل ايام رفع قوته العلم الروسي
على المركز الاداري الرئيسي في باخد